рік тому Росія почала широкомасштабну
війну проти України Я прокинувся у
третій ночі від якоїсь тривоги десь
справа від себе я почув вибухи тоді і
зрозумів що почалася війна
як довелося виживати мистецтво та
культурі Насправді Я не вірила що
вторгнення відбудеться я не могла
прийняти думку що це може статися в
реальному житті
троє культурних діячів Три долі та три
історії про те як Війна змінила їхнє
життя кожен епізод такий як Буча забирає
частинку тебе
[музика]
Коли настане день такі артисти як
Святослав Вакарчук робили все можливе
щоб йти далі Та не опускати рук
вони не хочуть щоб ще однією жертвою
війни стала українська культура
Насамперед тому що вона як ключовою для
ідентичності та згуртованості України
але як мистецтво переживає війну як воно
може чинити опір
[музика]
сірий зимовий день у Києві зустріч із
Альоною Альоною
реперка України Вона читає реп про
повсякденне життя та є рупором цілого
покоління
газета з нью-йорк Таймс назвала її
однією з 15 найважливіших європейських
поп-виконавців артистка згадує перші
миті війни
Мені було страшно адже я не знала що
робити немає інструкції Що саме ти
повинен робити коли війна приходить в
твою країну тому мені було порожньо і
страшно
як на свої вікно твоє нас ти не дасиш
потонути мені лірика Альони Альони пряма
і відверта проте ніколи не агресивна її
послання прогресивне
сьогодні Альона Альона виступає в ефірі
одного з українських телеканалів
співачка живе і працює між Києвом
Польшею Та й взагалі будь-якою точкою в
світі куди заведе її музика реперка вже
звикла До нескінченних перетинів
кордонів
Боже до тебе Ти над нами все чуєш І
бачиш як вогнем вкрилась мирне небо як в
підвалі дитя тихо плаче і хоч би як
співачка іноді не впадала у відчай вона
продовжує рухатися і не збирається
припиняти вірити і сподіватися трек
молитва це заклик до світу молитися за
Україну
Війна змінила творчий шлях артистки вона
стала значно більше виступати за
кордоном І хоча Альона Альона виступає
українською Європа є її слухає
зараз я відчуваю що ми повинні робити ще
більше і більше я щаслива що на всіх
фестивалях На всіх європейських сценах
кількістю українських артистів росте
мистецтво завжди допомагає налагодити
зв’язки з іншими країнами допомагає
зрозуміти нас дізнатися про нас щось
нове показати якими творчі
музика та соціальні мережі для Альони
Альони це майданчик для боротьби з
російською агресією на чолі з Путіним
усі пісні артистки мають політичний
зміст її чітка позиція знаходить палки
відгук в аудиторії особливо жіночий
[музика]
якою реперка бачить себе та Україну за
рік
я буду писати нові пісні можливо це буде
якась співпраця тому що ми маємо
пропозиції від артистів з різних країн і
це велика честь для мене Якщо говорити
про Україну то я знаю що ми виграємо
війну цього року і я знаю що Україна
буде частиною європейських країн
Альона Альона налаштована оптимістично
каже іншого вибору немає для неї музика
це засіб виживання та інструмент
протесту
твої руки бережуть
на тлі війни і руйнації які вона Тягне
за собою стіни стали полотном для вияву
спротиву навіть всесвітньо відомий
Street Art митець бенксі залишив свій
слід в Україні дівчата танцюють поряд із
ямами від снарядів діти перетворюють
протитанкові їжаки на гойдалки проти
Бенк всі лише один із багатьох
мурали та графіті це спосіб протесту
проти російського вторгнення Минулого
року вуличне мистецтво почало
поширюватися всією Україною такі
громадянські протести змінюють обличчя
зруйнованих війною українських міст
одні на фронті інші рятуються за
кордоном залишитися чи виїхати це
рішення з яким зіштовхнулося чимало
українських митців
чиєсь мистецтво може вижити лише в
еміграції з Києва ми прямуємо до Берліна
щоб зустрітися з популярною
мультимедійною українською артисткою
Діана азус вирішила виїхати з України
у перший день війни Мені не хотілося
нікуди їхати думаю що тоді я не приймала
реальність і я просто не відчувала що
можу кудись поїхати наприклад я не
бачила себе у Берліні але я думаю через
те що наступ не зупинився весь час
ескалація тривала ми дісталися через
Угорщину до Берліна очевидно що це дуже
темний рік для всіх нас можу сказати що
це один із найчорніших періодів мого
життя це відчуття втрати відчуття
тривоги хвилювання
Діана азус мультимедійна артистка яка
поєднує кіно музику та перформанс у 2021
році вона стала співзасновником лейбл
стандард dvation до російського
вторгнення Київ був популярною точкою
європейської клубної сцени азус грала DJ
сети по всьому місту зокрема і в
легендарному клубі 41
які очікування покладаються на митців у
вигнанні таких як Діана АЗОС як досвід
війни впливає на їхню творчість Діана на
фестивалі електронної музики в
берлінівськ
Діана азус з українсько-сирійської
родини росла в обох країнах дві
батьківщини дві війни А тепер еміграція
що не дає їй скласти руки
не можна перебувати у тривозі постійно
звичайно був період особливо перші
півроку коли я відчувала що нічого не
можу робити крім того знаєте є також
сильне відчуття спільноти тому що війна
об'єднала українців і я зрозуміла
наскільки Сильна Україна це також де є
сили рухатися далі та працювати
українець
[музика]
на фестивалі в Берліні Діана азус
презентувала свою першу роботу в
еміграції артистка створила відео за
допомогою штучного інтелекту музичний
супровід написала назанин норі це
гіпнотичний звуковий колаж такий же
темний і грізний як і світ образів Діани
АЗОС
[музика]
майбутнє не райдужне але Надія є гадаю
Це останнє що вмирає тож думаю якби ми
були повністю песимістами ми б не могли
продовжувати рухатися далі та
сподіватися що все може змінитися
до Києва на зустріч з українською
легендою лідером гурту Океан Ельзи
Святославом Вакарчуком
[музика]
пісня Обійми стала своєрідним гімном
не
відпускай на 50 день після російського
вторгнення Святослав Вакарчук виконав
Обійми серед руїн війни виступ показали
набієнале у Венеції цю мелодію знає чи
не кожен українець
погляди артиста за останні місяці також
змінилися
[музика]
відчуваю суміш найбільшої шаною гордості
перед українською мужжністю та героїзмом
перед нашими воїнами перед українцями а
також знаєте несподівано переживаючи
весь цей жах війни ти бачиш навколо себе
розруху вбивства поранених у шпиталях
усі ці ознаки війни
[музика]
Бій на світанні
сонце йти
мало хто знає
що ж буде з ним
такі проблемні ситуації я звертаюся до
музики насправді це рік музики для мене
якби це незвично не звучало б для людей
адже я багато займався музикою Ми дали
175 виступів на передовій ми вже дали 50
чи 60 концертів у Європі та інших
країнах і далі буде
Святослав Вакарчук часто відвідує
українських військових на передовій він
бачить війну на власні очі і пропускає
її через себе також артист виступає в
тилових містах ось приміром
імпровізований концерт у Києві
[музика]
ось цей жах і руйнування чи замислювався
він коли-небудь покинути музику
Я ніколи не втрачав віри в музику Музика
це мій літак насправді в Україні ми
воюємо не лише заради України Я думаю що
ми робимо це заради майбутнього всього
вільного світу західного світу всього
світу загалом
минулого року біля бранденбурзьких воріт
у Берліні Святослав Вакарчук співав на
благодійному концерті
зворушливий виступ слухала багатотисячна
аудиторія
те що відбувається в Україні показує що
навіть на війні Мистецтво відіграє
неоціненну роль мистецтво не просто
виживає воно процвітає
[музика]